Guys are you sure this is a good idea?
This place is creepy
Guys it'll be fun
Got some big plans
You expect me to cut my hand
and bring some vigilante ghosts
back from his grave?
Man, you crazy
Play the damn game
I saw them die
We were nothing but rag dolls to him
He was relentless
What do you know about Devilreaux?
The children's ghost story?
Most ghost stories have some basis in truth
The deadly night happened right out there
Jim?
Jim Michaels?
What in god’s name are y’all
Leonard stop
Leonard
I'm going to take your life
as payment
In full
The witch brought him back from the dead
to seek his revenge
Come home Come home
Devilreaux
Cursed the bloodline of all involved
Pause Proud of
Pa’s proud of you
My bloodline
Come home to us
I wanted to summon
the so-called boogeyman of the South
I just want to play the game
You'll called for him
and he came
Some have dubbed him the Lewa
the keeper of the graveyards
The giver of life
and the master of the dead